I meet people and I tell them what I do
and they often act very surprised and
they say something like really MIT has
music I didn't know that and I always
figured that that means they've never
actually been out to our campus because
if you walk around the infinite corridor
or building for there's just music
spilling out of the classrooms those
students playing music everywhere you
hear choir singing acapella groups
string quartets orchestras jazz bands
the listening room is a website where
you can go to sample a great variety of
the various types of music making that's
already going on on campus compositions
by faculty composers performances by
student ensembles etc there are 4,000
undergraduates at MIT and this term of
those 4,000 undergraduates 1,800 are
taking a course in either music or
theater there's sometimes a stereotype
about what an MIT student is like and in
my experience it's completely misleading
because the MIT students that I know
might be amazing computer programmers or
budding engineers but actually really
want to play the violin really want to
play the guitar and can do that very
well my name is Patti Tang and I meant
ethnomusicologist here at MIT I've been
teaching here since 2001 and my
specialty is Senegalese music
rhombic began as an extracurricular
activity when I first came to teach at
MIT in 2001 and over time it's grown to
be a huge ensemble with between 35 and
40 students per semester they're working
with with LeMay Natori who is an ester
governor from Senegal and the students
are not just learning drumming but
they're also learning about Senegalese
culture and sort of entire cultural
experience that comes along with with
learning to play an instrument the truck
from rumba that is available on the
listening room is a piece called tooth
tooth is a traditional Senegalese rhythm
that goes back for many many centuries
it's a rhythm that was traditionally
played for kings and Nobles or anyone
important who is entering an arena or a
room and tus is something that still
played to this day for the entry of an
important person
the peace of mind that's available in
the listening room is diamond watch
about a year and a half ago I had a
chance to write a piece for an important
occasion here at MIT which was the
retirement of one of our most
distinguished professors Peter diamond
and economics one of the things that
everyone knows about Peter diamond is
he's a gigantic baseball fan to me
there's only really one piece of music
that's associated integrally with
baseball to everybody and that's take me
out to the ballgame so I made a piece
for two pianos and I think the tune is
pretty clear even though I never stayed
it and it becomes more and more clear as
the piece goes along
I love occasional pieces and one of the
things I get to do around MIT
occasionally is write occasional pieces
I wrote a piece to go on the walls of
our music library I wrote a piece for
the inauguration of our new president
Raphael rife when I'm asked to do or
have a chance to do a piece that a lot
of my colleagues and students and so
forth in the community will hear it
makes me very happy
we're thrilled that the 2012-2013
academic year is the 50th anniversary of
the history of formal jazz study at MIT
you'll find three types of works
represented on the listening room site
one involves standard jazz compositions
by our major composers monk Ellington
Mingus and the other strean involves
original compositions by our current
students these might be arrangements of
standard tunes or more often their
original compositions themselves the
other category also involves original
compositions but from outside composers
some of the finest composers writing for
jazz today in spring of 1963 her palm
right legendary trumpeter and educator
and bandleader was brought to MIT at the
request of the students and the head of
the music department at that time cost
liepman to come and take over the
existing jazz ensemble that was at MIT
student let at that time and within a
short period of time
her primaries leadership magnificent
musicianship turned the program
completely around and that was in the
spring of 1963 and in honor of that
achievement in spring of 2013 we are
having a major celebration we've tried
to design our courses in our program
around the MIT model of learning by
doing so music making music is design
music is form music is structure music
is beauty music is elegance and you know
these are all things that are important
to any kind of design you do whether
it's music or otherwise so by doing
music they're literally thinking outside
of the box they're leaving what their
main focus is and they're using a
different part of their mind a different
part of their body a different part of
their being to think about the same
issues what makes something beautiful
what to make something have coherence
what's makes something have meaning or
shape then they go back to coding or
industrial design and they think about
it in a slightly different way